- piano music -
I'll be spark if you're going to be the torch
Start an insurmountable reaction
Balance your acidity (pH) by sharing two bases
I'll be your star if you're going to be a spaceman
Because there is no distance I will not go
Through space and time, the wormhole will materialize to the edge of the world (the wormhole is an imaginary wormhole located within the black holes)
I'll be you G if you will be C or I can be A if you will be T
If there is a boom you will fix every rule
I will work as zinc zinc zincide (allows zinc finger nuclei to target a unique or specific genetic sequence of content)
Just like an atom
Do not tear us apart
Unless you want a big explosion!
in my heart.
We can take it fast, or very slowly.
But we can not know exactly where we will go from.
If at first we did not succeed, we will try two more times
So our failure is a statistically significant attempt
Like an equation, everything works out
If we weigh the two sides there is no need to doubt
This is your scientific love song
Place to start our chemical association
With my research effort
We can write the conclusion together
Just like movies I would steal your heart
But if you do that you'll die ... so I will not do that.
If we break up, I will not be there anymore
I will give the water to sulfuric acid (when adding water to sulfuric acid - not the opposite - an interaction that could cause the explosion)
If they take away gravity, I'll stay stuck for you
I share your last electronic in a covalent bond for two
Because you are like an angel (corner), cute and intelligent (Angle has eyes)
Your lab coat and your protective glasses go directly to my heart
Except for that lie, because the heart does not feel
When it comes to love the brain seals the deal
This is the song of your scientific love
Place to start a chemical bond between us
With the research effort, we can write the conclusion together
With twenty footnotes and index
Because you are important to me (matter or important matter)
thanks for watching
If you love the song make sure you see it on iTunes and Bandcamp
You can also follow us on Instagram and Twitter in the links in the description below
Make sure to subscribe to AsapScience for more weekly science videos.
- See you next week